what I think a lot about is the science
around the art first 3 seconds thumbnail
what time do we post literally my team
we will post this today at 6:36 p.m.
ideal times today 4:04 and 636 one real
one image it is that specific for the
real recommendation is a real of you on
stage I promise you this is a level of
commitment that's very different than
post that picture so the science around
the art attention is the number one
asset would love to do a little Q&A and
maybe go a little more detailed I'm
ready go he's got something Gary you
talked about how you made Investments
early in some of the content companies
like Facebook do you think your
investments into those companies formed
your idea of what was important for the
future or do you think it was the
opposite the opposite the opposite what
what was very clear to me I referenced
it you know I launched an e-commerce
wine business in
1997 like for real not like hah haa like
I was operating it every day I I
remember people walking into my store
and asking them for their email to
create an account and like people didn't
even have email yet or they would say
funny things that I laugh about now I
remember one guy he's like oh yeah I
have one of those he's like I'm AOL
yahoo.com like that's not it brother you
know like and you know going from that
to people telling me they wouldn't put
their credit card into the computer to
running cataloges that used to cost me
$7,000 to print and and mail to now
sending an email for free and selling
more wine than I did two years ago in a
catalog with no cost so I was rolling
and then and then Google came out and
Google AdWords came out several months
later I bought Google AdWords the day
that Google AdWords were being sold and
was buying wine terms for 5 and 10 cents
a click and acquiring customers for
nothing so this was all happening and
then 2003 happened and it was starting
to be blogging and it was the first
thing I never got involved in because
even though I've written five near New
York Times bestselling books uh ROV are
you here where is he he's not here I'm
literally on my I'm going to leave right
now right after this and get on a flight
back to New York for 5 hours and my
ghost writer and a guy on my team ROV
who's was with me just now is literally
going to sit there with me and he's
going to read me back what I audio to
him so I can tweak a couple of the words
to finish up my book so blogging was the
first big Trend I saw that I wasn't able
to jump into cuz I can't write
and so when Friendster in Myspace came
out I was so pumped because I was like
this is the next wave this I understand
I was watching it and then my BR it's
all timing too my brother was a freshman
at be the first Facebook year and he and
be was like the third school to get it
and went like Harvard and a couple other
Boston Schools and he called me and he
came down for Thanksgiving and I looked
at it and I was like this is it and what
and the reason I said this was it was I
I'd gone from that was 97 in an 8-year
period we went from people not even
understanding the internet fully to them
people realizing they could look up re
you know look up remember it was like
more research if you think about the
beginning to now buying stuff and I just
knew that we were going to communicate
with each other on it and so no I
believe that the the next wave of the
internet was going to be human
connection and that's why those social
networks caught my attention Matt from
Ryder I we're the gener platform that's
sponsoring this today thanks for coming
uh Gary when you talk about LinkedIn and
how much of an opportunity it is can you
help us refine like what you see in that
opportunity and then we'll talk about
content creation that everyone here
regardless of what you want to happen
What customer do you want B2B B Toc or
by the way there are people in here who
might want a career change whatever your
objective is the fact that you could not
have this room have never posted in her
life if gar has never posted on LinkedIn
his life the fact that he can make a
video or written post about whatever he
wants to say post it on LinkedIn tonight
and that gets 800 people to see it is
crazy let me explain what I mean social
networking social networks for the last
15 years has been more like email you
get people to follow you you then post
and a percentage of them see it just
like email open rates right when I was
doing email in the late ' 90s 80 to 90%
of the people that got the email opened
it now 30% if you have a great email
right for some of I see some of the
heads nodding so you know it's supply
and demand of
attention the ticktock ification of all
social networks is the biggest Trend
going on in the world right now so the
example I just gave about Garrett five
years ago would have posted on LinkedIn
and one person would have saw it one of
the three people he has to follow him
cuz he decided he's going to start the
fact that his first post can get 800
because the algorithm is going to look
at the content and service it to a small
group of 20 or 30 random people that it
thinks will like what he had to say and
if of that 20 30 40 and I don't know the
exact numbers everyone's algorithm is
obviously very secret but a tiny group
of people will see it if it's compelling
to that group it will be brought into
more people's feed not only can he get
800 he could get a million very unlikely
needle and Hy stack but the fact that
that is true just think about what I
just said free distribution think about
how in expensive distribution is think
about how much you spend for a newspaper
ad a Google ad a television ad a booth
at a big conference like distribution
and awareness is expensive social
networks are free that is
insane and people do not understand the
severity of the insanity of how big that
is for the first time ever the quality
of your
message creates free distribution that
is
insane so what happens when creating
content is now dramatically less
expensive because of things like
generative AI how does that impact
LinkedIn uh you know it's going to come
it's it's going to impact everything
what's going to happen is a term called
prompt engineering is going to start to
be something everyone here knows what it
is so in a world where companies like
yourselves and many others take the
advantage way that I have I my personal
brand Gary ve the content you see I have
37 full-time employees
37 full-time employees who work on my
content making and distribution across
the eight platforms think about the
level of commitment that I've made for
that the fact that everyone here now can
buy a SAS product and make more content
than I make for a fraction of that will
mean that we will have more supply of
content than we've ever seen before I'm
not going to put my head in the sand
we're going to use generative AI as well
and Dustin and ragab they're going to
get fired and have to find new
jobs but what will happen I I'll finish
the thought is their jobs will have to
change what Dustin does incredibly well
as he films me but he's also paying
attention he's making notes there was uh
the gentleman he's not here who said you
inspired me in the talk just now I
called my son to say I'm sorry for being
a dick hey thanks for the inspiration I
took some action today talked to my son
this morning told him I sorry for being
a dick that's humongous yeah so you the
biggest thing made straight away that's
that means the world to me cheers to you
that means the world to me brother good
for you you can't imagine how big of a
deal that will be thank you you know how
much he appreciated that absolutely
absolutely good for you God bless proud
of
you you know it was a really emotional
thing for me that's a big deal that's
why I speak for a living like that
little moment but I looked at Dustin
when that happened and gave him my
contact and he made a note and that will
show up on my content in the next week
or so with all the Technologies coming
I'm not going to have to look at Dustin
we're going to upload that video it's
going to understand rhythms and patterns
from AI of things that have worked for
me and me and Dustin in our gut are no
longer going to do post- production the
AI is going to figure it out and put it
out what is that going to mean supply
and demand issues and so what's going to
happen is it's going to be harder to
break through because everyone's going
to be doing it and so you're going to
have to be better so my question to you
Gary is what is attention pcking can you
give
some examples and some best practice
Yeah so I'm writing a new the book I'm
working on which will come out next year
is actually called day trading attention
right that's how that's how I think
about what I do for a living if you you
know obviously I think the term day
trading is something most of the people
here will know somewhere along the line
with technology Wall Street became
second to Second not hour to hour with
paper it became day trading on your
computer so hacking attention or the way
I think about it day trading is a very
simple and complicated game where are
you all spending your time where like
where are your eyeballs and ears going
it you know 50 years ago was television
and newspapers and so you you would try
to then make the best print ad to make
you buy I did that in my career I used
to spend a week making my New York Times
full page ad a week I would be eight
hours a day a week should I put this
wine in this corner should I have a
coupon down here like real
thinking now that same thinking goes
into the first 3 seconds of every video
I put on LinkedIn it goes into the
thumbnail some of my friends here are
doing a really good job on LinkedIn we
were hanging out backstage and I said to
him hey you got to pay attention to the
copy because Linked In only the first 50
letters show up and then you have to hit
you know learn more most people won't do
that if you have a call to action Link
in the first 50 thing you're going to
get a higher retention right or you know
or how do you actually think about
what's happening you're all doing it all
of you minimum I'm I'm aware that some
of you don't have anything not LinkedIn
not Facebook but the far majority of
this room is doing this on something Tik
Tok Facebook Instagram LinkedIn YouTube
shorts how do you get someone to stop
especially with more content coming so
what I think a lot about is the science
around the art first three seconds
thumbnail words what time do we post
literally right now I'll show him and
you can confirm it to you my team this
is the thread with the whole team on it
look at the look at this we will post
this today at 6:36 p.m. it is that
specific like you know and like like
read the ideal times today 4:04 and 636
one real one image for re for the real
recommendation is a real of you on stage
I promise you this is a level of
commitment that's very different than
post that picture so the science around
the art but then also following trends
like when Travis Kelce and Taylor Swift
are eating up popular culture is there
any way for you to interject into that
conversation that doesn't feel forced
how clever are you how creative are you
you know you know like uh I saw really
good post by a B2B company where the two
heads of the company uh one was called
one one's person's name was Travis and
one was Taylor they were both dudes but
it was perfect right cuz you know like
they were able to like make reference
and I looked back it was their highest
performing post ever right so I'm I'm
looking at the pulse of society you know
how many people lost customers by
posting during inappropriate times so
you have to have a feel for the room
which is the world you have to know your
demos I'm making content on LinkedIn for
just VCS and the next post just to get
clients and the next post just to get
talent to apply to Vayner media all
three of those videos are very different
I was telling those guys everything they
make is just about selling the SAS but
they should make videos to get better
Talent on their sales team they should
make better they should make videos
about how they run company culture they
should make by the way a thing that all
of you should do on LinkedIn is make a
post about your interests maybe it's
French wine maybe it's golf maybe you're
playing pickle ball you might post on
LinkedIn that you have fallen in love
with pickle ball go into the fact that
that hour now every day that you play
pickle ball in the morning makes you
fresher to be better at work and because
someone who you're trying to reach as a
customer or an employee also likes
pickle ball that just created
consideration based on relevance for
them to do business with you so
everyone's showing up in LinkedIn in
their suit and tie right but but
in reality in reality you need to show
that version and this version definitely
that you're in you know notice I always
say watch what I'm doing not what I'm
saying like or you know like like pay
attention to how I give a keynote like I
will make references to the New York
Jets I will make references to Wine I'm
creating connection points and all of
you should be doing that in your content
if you're just saying the same thing of
like our Tech works better like cool but
like like you can only say it so many
times AI company should be talking about
Time Savings you put a photo of a person
watching their child play basketball in
a gym and then you say use our Tech and
save an hour every day so you can go
watch your kid play basketball watch how
many people stop that's a very different
emotional connection point cuz
inevitably somebody on the other side of
that LinkedIn post is sitting in the
office right now missing a recital or a
game and feels we all are modern parents
we feel like our parents didn't
give a we you know we're we feel
like we feel like and all of a
sudden that hits you and say wait a
minute maybe that's why I should pay up
for the tech cuz I do want that hour
back cuz I do want to eat dinner with my
family once a week and like that's real
just the real way humans work and
so my efficiency on that post will go up
this is like real like I think I
it's why I laugh how people think about
social media people look at social media
like it's bad it's ruining the world or
my kids all up or it like it is
disproportionately the most significant
engine of business growth on Earth and
there isn't a close second and yet
everyone is Lally gagging the out
of it there are less than two handfuls
of people in that audience that have the
commitment towards LinkedIn that is
required for an IND IND like this that
will actually drive their business they
will spend so much more energy designing
their booth for this incredible
conference than they will for all their
content on LinkedIn this whole year and
this is a big time this is the Apex
Super Bowl event but it's still only
three days there's another 362
days and not everyone's here and
you're not going to serendipitously run
into everyone you're trying to get to
here no matter how late you stay up
tonight you know and so I don't
understand how people don't understand
the scale comes from LinkedIn on that
note you talked about dust I want that
for
something
see no no you what fascinates me is you
said you have a staff of 37 for your
personal brand and then an agency right
in Vander Medan and 2,000 other
employees and then V friends has 50
employ how important how important is it
for for everyone to have a personal
brand Focus Beyond just the business
that they I don't I don't think it's a
requirement I don't think it's a I don't
think everyone needs to have a personal
brand I think everyone should consider
it it's not for everyone there's a lot
of baggage that comes with being a
public figure now most people won't have
the level of public figuress that I have
so I think for a lot of people
especially in a B2B environment I think
it's epic cuz there's nobody here who's
the next Taylor Swift or Charlie
demilio like it's not that kind of
industry for that so I think but what it
will be is it leads to you being on it
leads to this conference inviting you to
be on stage next year like there's a lot
of value in it in B2B B Toc is a little
scarier because it can change your life
if you became internet famous your
life's different and there's a lot of
baggage that comes along with that and a
lot of people don't even I'll be honest
with you I'm I'm not very interested in
how many people here really follow me
like just for context so all of you know
I don't share my personal life I'm I'm
deeply private deeply private I just am
so aware of the business ramifications
of it but why why did I say that you're
in control you don't want you don't want
people in your business don't post it I
think to remind people first it's not
for everyone and it's okay you don't
have to but I do think a lot of people
think of it as only like high energy
Dynamic person it's not there's a lot of
very introverted very thoughtful very
articulate very deep thinking writers
that Crush especially for this industry
you go write a white paper that really
is right about what's happening and like
talks about your solution and why it
will work you will be stunned how much
that will work so you got to find your
way of communicating I I think it's
worth considering but it's not a
requirement there are plenty of people
have monster businesses that has no
personal brand attached to it it also
could lead to happiness let me explain
so now you're getting going a little bit
with what we're talking about here but
you start you remember like wait a
minute he did mention that I could post
other stuff and you post your first ever
video cooking ever you love to cook it's
your place it's where you feel like
you're most you you're even a little
funnier a little more Dynamic right and
you just film cooking a meal and you're
talking and you just post it and it
explodes and you find yourself 2
years from now being literally a food
influencer making more money with Brands
supporting your food videos than you
were doing being a senior executive I
believe it is a path to happiness I just
I genuinely believe a lot of people here
have deeper passions than what you're
doing right now for your living and I
think it's worth potentially scratching
those itches so Gary on stage you have a
very uh specific way that you exhibit
yourself and use hands gestures and you
have your hat you know is all that by
choice the reverse the reverse yeah it's
really funny I love that both your
questions kind of have the same answer
when I first hit the scene I wrote a
book in 2009 called crush it which
really talked about what I thought was
going to happen and ended up happening
with social media and all this it went
very viral I was pretty unknown I was in
the wine world but definitely not in the
business world and I started getting
asked to speak and I don't know if you
picked up on this but I
curse um and I'm very casual and today
what I the way I'm dressed on stage even
in an event like this you can kind of
somewhat get away with it the
casualization of business over the last
15 years has happened in 2009 it wasn't
there yet and CIA was my speaking bureau
at the time and they called me cuz I was
cuz I was naturally good at it I didn't
know that I was a good public speaker
and you can see how I speak it's very
improv it's very like it's not a
presentation even for the people that
follow me the most they they'll see
things that I say often but there's
always new it's contextual my
speaking bureau reached out to me like
pretty aggressively in like a good way
they came from a good place like bro you
could be like a legitimate speaker like
you could be big like this could work
for you and it's very lucrative but you
have to start wearing a suit and you
can't curse and they didn't even finish
the sentence and I said to them you just
I'm like thank you cuz they were coming
from a good place I'm like you just
don't know me I'm not capable of that
I'm just really great at one thing which
is being comfortable in my own skin and
dealing with the ramifications of that
pro and con that is my greatest skill
set so all of that is just really how I
live my life and I'm okay that people
won't book me to speak CU they don't
want someone to curse or they think it's
disrespectful to be too casual I respect
that that's their house that's their
event they're allowed but I'm not
interested in feeling uncomfortable
because I can't be my best self when I'm
speaking I want to impact people like I
all of you just saw that talk I was like
reinforcing over and over the same thing
because I know the three little there's
like three or four things for that
Collective group knowing there was a lot
of different people in there those were
the three things that if they did better
would happen and like if I'm not
comfortable I'm not going to be able to
authentically like hit do you know what
I mean and I'm aware that there's people
in there that thought it was
inappropriate that I cursed I believe
that every time like I believe that and
I respect that but but I also know on
the flip side that talk has much more
impact on the collective than most talks
that would be given and that's all you
could ask for right have as big of an
impact so no I don't I don't I'm not
like Vince McMahon and like creating a
character that I think will work I just
got very fortunate that the world went
in my direction I'm I always think about
myself of like who the hell would have I
been if I was was doing business in the
60s 7s and 80s it would have been tough
cuz I wouldn't have gone there and it
just I would have been some sort of
different thing I mean it might have
been better I might have been very
unique and a Trailblazer but um no I'm
I'm just not comfortable of doing
anything that do come naturally to me I
just always feel like it's icky and off
and me like not in my pure form is like
bad my last kind of insure Tech was an
employment in space did the VC train
build it Soul got acquired integrated in
left starting a venture Studio curious
with the py landscape the pros cons of
the Venture Studio model do asset class
I mean the Venture Studio concept which
I've flirted with a lot these are like
where you're incubating multiple
businesses you're you know I assume
you're bringing in some Founders you on
a piece like it's you know honestly I
really really love that concept cuz I'm
very creative and I have a 100 ideas so
I think this will be your most enjoyable
Venture because you're going to be able
to scratch a lot of inches um what
inevitably happens in these models is if
you're good one's going to take off and
then that's going to eat up a lot of
energy so you got to keep that in mind
if you want that or not want that but
what do I think I think money's
expensive right now there's nobody in
this industry that's confused by
interest rates so money's expensive so
it changes all the rules the VCS have
all the leverage after they have had
none in the last decade like you
literally had to beg people to take your
money think about that it's crazy right
now VCS have the leverage which I think
is more appropriate I think it was a
little frothy a little I don't
think people were building companies
they were building Financial Arbitrage
machines trying to get to it you know
what I mean so me personally I think VC
being a VC right now is great your money
is more valuable it's harder to get LPS
so it depends on how much powder you're
sitting on and then as far as a venture
Studio model I think the more creative
you are the more it's the right model
because otherwise you're just a
financier and that's boring for
operators we're dealing like hybrid too
it's not just about unicorns if it's
cash flow like creating cash fig I know
right a lot yeah I know I know but
that's because Venture Capital just
wants to show a multiplier to raise more
LP like it's a full ecosystem I think I
think you're going down in the right way
but be on next venture you know what's
funny I similar to the other questions
like I don't I'm a I'm a counter puncher
I'm a counter puncher what does that
mean it means that I don't sit and say I
want my next venture to be bubble gum or
sass that like what I because I day
trade attention I'm just kind of
constantly watching I'll give you I'll
give you themes that you might find
interesting I'm completely infatuated
with the continent of Africa the sheer
talent and brain power and the youth I
think the stat goes something like in
the next 15 years like 35% of the people
under 25 in the world will live on the
continent of Africa so like it I like
using history as a predictor so if you
really pay attention to what's happened
in the Middle East in the last 30 years
you can see a very obviously there's so
many different geopolitics there's a lot
that's different but there's a lot
that's the same so so for example I
don't know what my next venture is but I
know that I'm incredibly bullish on
Africa and so what that will do is it
will make me read for two hours about
things going on in Africa which may lead
to something as interesting as oh
there's a super fruit that only grows in
Kenya right that I know the African
Market in the next 30 Years is going to
be mature as a consumer Market but I
could also import it to the US and get
all the coastal people that are trying
to live that life curious I I did that
with monk fruit my my fiance is very
healthed out and like she's like in
Pillow Talk she's like she's like you
have to do something with monk fruit and
I pulled up an email that I sent to Phil
Toronto in 20 who works for me in
2013 and it just said monk fruit we need
to research it she was blown away and it
was like a perfect story I could tell
all of you of like how I actually work I
stay uncomfortably curious around
different thesises and then because of
that right so I'm building a Pokemon
meet Sesame Street intellectual property
called vriends I've been wanting to
build something like it for a long time
originally was called workplace Warriors
I was going to do little toys and
figurines at for your desk cuz I think a
lot of us know like what cubicles look
like but I bought Bitcoin and ethereum
in 2013
15 like and was watching it and then
when I saw the nft thing was starting to
mature I decided to launch the IP as an
nft while equally making videos that 99%
of nfts were going to go to zero so it's
a very like complex like I'm all in on
the macro be careful of the micro but
now I'm like very far along yesterday I
was in New York City on a float for the
Halloween parade trading if you go to
eBay right now and type in vriends
you'll be blown away what the pins and
stickers and trading cards I'm
announcing a major YouTube kids
initiative with some of the biggest
animators in the world like I'm actively
building a Marvel a Hello Kitty a
Pokemon right now I would have I didn't
really think three years ago that that's
what I was going to do so I'm staying I
stay very curious about a lot of things
and then I act on it but you have to be
careful to not just follow a trend
because you think it's a trend crypto
this cannabis that right AI this you see
those kind of people who are just always
on to the next thing for me I am on to
the next thing a lot but it's always
fitting a strength or something I've
been thinking about it's why I started a
marketing company first after I left my
dad's business I knew that marketing was
my superpower so I wanted to build a
huge infrastructure do you guys know
resi the restaurant app yeah that was
incubated at Vayner media I the
co-founder of resi so resi was built
inside of Vayner with people outside and
inside of Vayner joining it I started a
direct a consumer wine brand called
empathy wines that I sold to consolation
so I'm I built a marketing
infrastructure almost like an operating
system so that I can then groom that
talent and then put them into other
Ventures who know my way which is very
much what I spoke about like what I
spoke about is unique like I really do
care about kindness in the workplace and
like safety like like you know I'm
pretty sure most of the Keynotes at this
conference over the years have not spent
15 minutes on kindness in company
culture I think it's foundational and so
you can imagine I'm better off grooming
talent that believes in it because it's
hard to teach people it because they
don't believe you everybody says they
care about culture but nobody does so
these are things I think about so thank
you thank
[Music]
you